bueno pues esta extensión del tratado
limita a 1.550 las ojivas nucleares que
pueden estar ubicadas a vía urgencia por
renovar este tratado por que caducaba en
el 5 de febrero en pocos en pocos días
esta extensión del tratado no pone
límite a todas las armas nucleares pero
de momento por lo menos evita una
carrera armamentista hasta ahora no
había sido posible acordarlo porque el
anterior presidente de eeuu donald trump
había exigido que china se sumarse al
acuerdo pero pekín había descartado
hacerlo esgrimiendo que ellos apenas
tienen 300 armas nucleares desplegadas
es solo el principio porque de hecho
este acuerdo no revierte otras
decisiones de trama como por ejemplo
ahora haber salido de acuerdos como el
de las armas nucleares de alcance
intermedio y hay algunas armas rusas
como por ejemplo algunos drones
nucleares submarinos que no está claro
que estén dentro de este armamento pero
por lo menos significa una escalada
hacia abajo en la tensión que han venido
protagonizando eeuu y rusia en los
últimos años